pensez-y peu en parlent d'eux adel la
chanteuse alors on en parle beaucoup
parce qu'elle a posté une photo à une
photo a été postée d'elle très très
maigre elle a perdu 45 kilos en quelques
mois quand même
alors on s'est posé des questions
faut-il s'inquiéter ou pas les mauvaises
langues disaient d'un nouvel album qui
va sortir il ya un peu de buzz moi j'ai
du mal à penser qu'on perd 45 kg pour la
sortie d'un album ou alors vraiment
l'album est mauvais faut-il s'inquiéter
oui non oui non oui non non toi qui vas
qui connaît bien les people non non pas
de voir parce que d'abord je pense que
si c'est une perte de poids de cet
acabit en si peu de temps peut-être
qu'elle a tout simplement bien un anneau
et que dans ces cas là la perte de poids
et rapides peut-être qu'elle avait des
problèmes de santé liés à son poids qui
fait hacker maigri donc moi elle a l'air
très bien et très heureux de sa perte de
poids donc toi t'as pas d'écho aux états
unis de problèmes de santé de tous à
temps c'est plutôt quelque chose de
calculé
elle suit le régime food die est donc
c'est à base beaucoup de jus vert & or
never
ouais voilà et donc les trois premiers
jours s'est mis à elle peut manger que
1000 calories ensuite mais on passe à
1500 mhz est entré c'est bien encore
nouveau régime américain bien 24 c'est
bien c'est une star je pense qu'elle a
toutes les mairies à ce sommet la cabine
en totu n'est pas inquiet non pas
inquiète parce que je pense que déjà
comme l'a expliqué rachel elle est très
très bien entouré en plus de ça on a
appris qu'elle venait de divorcer donc
moi je pense que quand on divorce on a
un changement j'ai envie d'être
mais au-delà de ça enfin on a envie un
petit peu de faire regretter son ex on a
envie de changement
d'accord on va dire donc toi t'as fait
ça paraît aussi que du change de mec qui
change de coiffure anges des mecs je
suis une bombe je me mets en bond la
thermos de quoi que tu étais très belle
la tauromachie c'est en couple c'est là
c'est pour vous c'est la saint-valentin
ouais c'est donc c'est pas pareil à ce
soir tu fais quoi
j'attends je vois ce que mon chéri mon
propos est arrivé à eelv ateliers
d'éveil prépare une surprise à l'enquêté
ring diallo cadbury
tonna rien c'est quoi mais il a vraiment
fait c'est quoi garde
je vais demander qui t'a offert salma
this est dédié à marie c'est pas vrai
bah oui c'est du diamant idiote c'est
magnifique
comment il s'appelle que l'on peut dire
il s'appelle monsieur date
comment must à mu date très bien moi
j'ai quand même fasciné par dont
dépendent tous ces gens de télé réalité
on va reparler tout à l'heure ça brasse
abras des sceaux 4 700 milles ça je te
demanderai pas le cri parce que c'est
vulgaire mais ça coûte combien faut lui
demander à lui basile et je ne connais
pas ça se demande pas ça bouge ça les
mois environ
environ moi je te connais tu as vu comme
tout le monde est à capuchon google pour
un prix de ton cadeau enfin le prix du
cadeau n'est pas affichée mais pour
revenir à adel
[Rires]
justement quand tu divorces bat a besoin
d'un changement
j'ai bien compris et c'est plein de bon
sens que dit non mais absolument le sexe
et amour c'est ta nouvelle meilleure
amie a tenté mais pas un mot
mr rip beaucoup premier montage mais
mais pourquoi j'essaye tout inquiète
moi je suis père accepte parce que
maigrir aussi vite et autant c'est hyper
inquiétant pour la santé parce que même
si elle se pose se poser un anneau ou
quoi je trouve que c'est violent
l'image qui alors qu'elle dégage si
adele on a l'habitude de la voir un peu
avec ses formes on a l'habitude enfin
moi moi ça me fait peur quand je la vois
comme ça ça m'angoisse
et justement je me dis est ce qu'elle
est pas en train de plonger dans une
dépression parce que elle vient de
divorcer
deux erreurs et je me dis bah moi je
suis d'accord avec ça parce qu'elle
était très joyeuse adèle c'était la
fille qui buvaient de la bière qui
bouffe et les chiffres c'est qu'il
faisait sans vergogne franchement
c'était la grosse neige vraiment moche
c'est vrai c'est comme ça qu'elle était
un jovial way et depuis qu'elle est
qu'elle a divorcé qu'elle adorait son
mari qui était très moche aussi
d'ailleurs
elle a quitté son envie était formulée
les amis non mais bien des noms en
fallait encore et surtout
ceku figurent robert guy talent bien sûr
toutes les infos sur le sac les vrais a
tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tb beatles et la saint-valentin joyeuse
saint valentin à tous vous des petits
cadeaux et tout ça d'abord vos organes
tpm d'épisodes après castel dit on
embrasse et puis et puis après vous
venez de fêter la saint valentin tout ça
c'est très bien c'est très bien dans un
attendra beaucoup d'infos repas du sac
de nabila avons fait un vrai débat parce
qu'on a tous tes infos vous doutez avec
une nouvelle chronique notamment qu'on a
aujourd'hui
milla jasmin qui est avec nous et qui
influencent euse on a beaucoup d'infos
avec magali également sur le vrai la
vraie histoire du sac de nabila on a
tout dit de 700000 euros jusqu'à 33
mille euros est ce que c'est un cadeau
pas un cadeau ou alors on va vraiment
vous dire toute la vérité autour de ce
sac dit on m'a appelé après software
mais si hier il a fait ce qu'on appelle
julien courbet dans le milieu vous
écoutez la radio avec oui bonjour madame
c'est julien courbet je vous le propose
rtl pointe de chaudières la demie pipe
guillaume hier c'est par accrocher cette
fois on est à peu près hermès il rappelé
bonjour c'est que frisquet j'aimerais
vous parler sa ruse presse du saguenay
déjà peu plus on fait toutes les
semaines en parle de la dame qui me l'a
dit c'est qu'il a d'inde
[Applaudissements]
toutes les semaines on en parle comme
celui-là d'invertébrés oui ça l'a
d'abord yo yo je les aime beaucoup de l
a très bien réussi tromelin parle parce
que ça marche aussi et 4 et 4 shito pèse
toujours par germées d'une ferme
traitant d'un présent qui présente des
excuses bébé à quel niveau
c'est pas une dinde
voilà merci on fera pas mieux que les
amis on continue on était en train de
parler justement alors on parlait on
était dans le ça s'est passé cette
semaine
à noter sur ada effectivement adel qui a
perdu 45 kg et on disait ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter ou pas mais leur visa no10
est non comme elle elle s'est séparée le
nouvel album sort mais finalement voilà
a cédé signal vélv elle veut reconquérir
le monde et les hommes et d'autres
disent au contraire
ben non justement parce qu'elle n'est
pas en train de tomber dans la
dépression et monaco 2-2 alors justin
justin mais on suit la suite à son
divorce ou quand il ya des aléas le
divorce
ouais alors on veut changer de vie elle
se dit j'ai ton temps en plus donc ça
correspondait et donc elle se dit elle
elle fait cette espèce de régime et là
on voit qu'après quand on compte les
calories lacombe boire une soupe le
matin machin espère à elle est dans
l'hyper contrôler c'est quand même cette
hyper contrôle on sait qu'il peut amener
après qu'elle a un nouveau mec qui a une
rumeur comme quoi je serais avec harris
times l'ancien de one direction
on était super pote ouais et là il
paraît qu'ils ont passé la vitesse
qu'ils ont passé l'été sera très bon la
photo du jour sa sagesse sa kora ça
confirme dans l'oreillette me dit oui ni
d'accord donc elle coûtera cariste
albalad la drôle de couple un faut pas
s'inquiéter les pas morte adèle déjà
4 hier catherine m'angoisser traite et
dans l'émission non la seule chose un
peu faut rappeler un truc effectuant la
grossophobie c'est pas bien mais
malheureusement on risque plus d'être en
mauvaise santé quand on est trop et au
oui on tourne et romain sauf si on fait
de l'anorexie ce qui arrive qui est une
maladie rare talent mais bref on sait
maintenant il ya peut-être un problème
est ce qu'elle va pas être plus du tout
en adéquation avec son public moi je
pense à une comédienne que j'adorais qui
était dans j'arrive jamais a prononcé
mon ami dans le journal de bridget jones
est inchangé
sa carrière s'est arrêtée à la halle aux
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vins sont utilisés on va toujours bien
mais tu est hermann ya de temps en temps
il ya des pantalons figurant dans la
connerie les enfants une petite île à
lui dix ans de galère wolo ce cas là
c'est vrai quand on a un oscar n'est pas
que maigret alabau si beaucoup changé
selon lui elle a perdu un petit peu de
poids elle a perdu du poids d'un oscar
faut s'inquiéter réunion